[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
dumb William here we are here we are
indeed
are you comfortable financially no just
like where your butt is yeah these
chairs are quite comfy actually I would
like to be a little bit more you know
skewed towards you yeah we should
probably at some point do that because
why why are we like I feel like that you
know like our avant-garde theater where
they they the people don't talk to each
other they talk out to the audience you
know when they're talking to each other
that's what we're like an avant-garde
podcast I've always felt that we were
there anyway we're always on the edge
aren't we I feel a little bit like I'm
on a comfy Throne yeah me too but we we
should have something why
in a podcast where it's about
conversation we we don't we don't
actually look at each other yeah that's
true maybe we could ask uh let's go okay
yeah you could ask him you might not get
my job it doesn't look like he knows too
much to be honest
peeling The Onion
uh we've had some questions should we
jump into these let me just get come
this is another thing I think about this
seat John I'd like to be on one side or
the other I don't like being in the
middle I feel like it's a it's too it's
too wide so I like to be on one side
yeah get kind of squished in one side or
the tether but anyway let me get
comfortable and then hit me with a
question you get comfortable because
this is actually a question for you go
and then from Elise in Washington United
States Washington State or Washington DC
well she didn't stipulate well there's
two of them isn't it yes there is them
hello Elise she said Billy yeah you got
the news that you had been cast in rent
did you find out what character you
originally cast as
who were you going for I did uh it
wasn't no I forget his name now is that
he's the filmmaker there's a rock star
never seen it there's a filmmaker
and it's a filmmaker how do you document
real life when real life's getting more
like a fiction each day that's what it
says
so his life is getting more like a film
and he's trying to uh capture what real
life feels like he didn't get it did you
no I didn't give a told that you got it
I was told I got it you didn't get it I
didn't get it and I really wanted it
but um it's the guy the filmmaker uh and
I forget his name that's terrible Rogers
the rock star
Angel is a lovely part
and then it's not Keith it's like Keith
people out there are screaming at you
what it is that's all right
what does he say his name is
uh maybe yeah it does
don't read the questions otherwise
you'll know what it is well I don't know
the answer
podcast
hey Craig Deacon from Germany from
landstule oh
lovely pronunciation there do you know
what that is no
right we'll carry on there hey fellas he
says I'm reaching out from Landstuhl
Germany I was watching Fellowship of the
Ring I was wondering if you could tell
me more details uh on when the Orcs And
cave troll was attacking in the main
submaria for example yo attack the cave
troll after Frodo got stabbed by The
Troll and you jumped on them
what was used for that scene what did
you jump on because I wasn't a troll
there he's saying no there wasn't Tom
if there is something you would like me
to send you from Germany let me know I
know you've spent some time there and
we're even born there up at that bed oh
yeah good thanks thanks guys uh and then
he says there's a throwaway at the end I
love you Billy and the same goes to you
but it doesn't really mean that um it
meant that more for you because you've
got the kind of German Heritage as it
were cheers I love Germany you know that
it's one of my favorite countries I know
that word that's a good one to remember
in Germany I'm sure you've heard before
juice juice it's a little bit like ciao
yes cheers see you later cheers
yeah it's lovely all right sound good
well the question yeah we attacked a
cave troll what was used for the scene
when we jumped on him well
[Music]
I want to hear you because I've got a
feeling that your memory of this is not
right it's going to be foggy my
recollection of it is that it's not
actually us it's a computer-generated
version of us jumping onto a
computer-generated troll or is that not
correct
that's not 100 correct sorry man only
one of us jumped on the troll dump oh it
was me really what did you jump on uh
the Jackson
there was a few different things but
like when we were fighting a troll and
hiding behind the thing you know if you
remember sometimes it was just a tennis
ball and a stick remember that so just
so that we were all looking at the right
thing for his eyes basically yeah but
they they did have
um uh obviously that what it was going
to look like and and people is in the
computer and said this is what the troll
will be writing how he moves so that you
know and um ever modest the scene where
Amon is back
can't a hundred percent remember what I
was on but I remember I did have to do I
had to jump off it and do a forward roll
oh which yeah that was quite exciting
yeah but I think it was just there was a
few different things sometimes I was
some I was actually on like a a stunt
man and sometimes it was like you know
just on a sort of thing that they built
off the ground and would
and looking at you you were down track
stab him and no I was there I was there
for you giving you an eye line because
you didn't have one from the cave troll
and I was happy to do it well you
started off by saying I think your
memory is about the Cape Town are going
to be vague dumb and your memories about
the game trial were quite vague yeah
yeah you've been hoisted by wrong button
but I do remember doing it and I
remember it being quite an exciting
thing no cave troll thing in there yeah
that sequence was great because all the
fellowship were encased in Moria
together and we were there all day there
was a lovely feeling on set because
there was a nice little fun Dynamic
teasing between the humans and The Elves
and the Elves and the dwarves and the
hobbits were in their own little thing
right yeah Ian McCallum was in a good
mood and he was winding up Vigo and yeah
Orlando and we were all having fun it
was it was a great feeling I think we
were all just a bit
Giddy and excited by just how incredible
that set was because Moria was one of
the best wasn't This brilliant
Incredibles everywhere I'm not going to
get uh
super into the the rings of power right
now the TV show the TV show
um because we might speak a little bit
about that show today with our fantastic
guests true but I will see one of the
things I like best about it is when
there's characters that you're like oh
that character was in Lord of the Rings
somehow like during like that was the
his tomb we were in and then to see him
on TV now like and seeing his story yeah
and I do think the actor plays during
this fantastic he's very good and I love
seeing Moria looking so healthy and you
know it's a place where a great
Community is strong elevators
some very cool stuff in there yeah well
thank you Craig uh we've got one last
question here from the Loveless Sophie
Harris Sylvie Harris from she didn't say
where she was from she's just leaving it
just as a question it's just from planet
Earth she said hi guys why do moths love
light so much like light bulbs and phone
screens and I'm interested to see what
Billy thinks about this if you were to
answer it well I do moth why are moths
attracted to I've known you for a long
time done and if I get this wrong this
would be very embarrassing I'm sure that
a few people have asked you that over
the years Don been an expert of uh moths
and other flying creatures
and also creatures that crawl and walk
and two and four legs creatures six and
eight creatures in general but a lot of
flying nocturnal creatures are attracted
to lights aren't they here's what I'm
thinking done you tell me
they think it's the moon oh good and the
thing I'll fly towards that
for a reason that is beyond me but they
do think it's the moon they do think
it's the moon but why would they be
flying towards the Moon Yeah well so
you've got half of it right well thanks
yeah those those animals do navigate by
the Light of the moon but obviously
the Moon is a long way away from them so
what they do is they keep the moon a
certain kind of angle gradient to where
they fly and they always keep it let's
say for the sake of argument two they're
left at 45 degrees so they know if
they're going to turn right right facing
the opposite direction from where they
go yeah but with an artificial light
being so close they think well I'll just
fly in the direction of the thing that's
my kind of North Star and then I'll work
it out but then they get caught in a
little Cyclone where they're trapped now
with no Direction because they've hit
the thing that they're navigating by do
you know what I mean happened to me once
playing Blind Man's buff and my Grands
uh hallway you know Blind Man's buff
basically you're blindfolded and you're
trying to catch other kids yeah
so I get stuck in the corner and the
corner of a hallway only has two walls
and for some reason Dom I could not get
out of there
so you went left right left right
couldn't work it out I couldn't work out
all your pals were laughing at you
earlier what do you think were hum I was
like a moth at the light moth to a flame
and obvious so obviously a lot of flying
animals do that
spiders are very smart because they tend
to put up their webs close to artificial
lights now so that they don't have to do
all the work the animals will come to
them yeah you'll see that a lot around
that's amazing when you and I were in
Thailand yeah any light that goes up all
the spiders and all the all the snakes
and lizards will just hang out by that
light waiting for food to come to them a
spider's web has to be one of the most
amazing things I've already yeah there's
an animal that
makes its own trap yeah out of its what
but is it yeah this abdomen yeah and can
make different consistency in that web
right so it can make some that it uses
for it to like shelter in yeah it's
little you know Hideaway and then
somebody uses to trap animals and then
some that when the animal shows up it
produces a very sticky webbing so they
can trap it very quickly so they can
create different consistencies to that
webbing amazing super incredible
now a word from our sponsor better help
it can be tough to train your brain to
stay in a problem-solving mode when
faced with a challenging life but when
you learn how to find your own Solutions
there's no better feeling a therapist
can help you become a better Problem
Solver making it easy to accomplish your
goals no matter how big or how small
that's right Tom sometimes you just need
to speak to someone about your problems
otherwise you keep them inside and you
can spiral into that problem yeah rather
than thinking about well how am I going
to fix this yeah and it's great to talk
to friends and family but sometimes
there's nothing better than speaking to
a professional and that's what better
help does very very well absolutely if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online you can get matched with
a therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists anytime you
like when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com onion today and get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash onion
remember the days before streaming
services when you would just come home
from high school and it was only a few
hours until that TV show that everyone
was watching was going to come on your
friends were on their way over for a
watch party and the smell of popcorn
filled the room well in 1999 that
particular show was one of Billy's
favorites Buffy the Vampire Slayer well
in the new podcast from wondering The
re-watcher Buffy the Vampire Slayer we
are taking it back to 1999. get out your
knee-high boots and Pace that poster of
angel on your wall it's time to enter
the buffyverse join morbid co-stars Ash
and Elena as they slay their way through
Buffy's Drama Action and romance Episode
by episode and to the buffyverse with
Alana and Ash listen to The re-watcher
Buffy the Vampire Slayer on Amazon music
Apple podcast or listen early and
ad-free by subscribing to wondering Plus
in apple podcast or the wandery app buff
Me Baby One More Time
William what is it John look to your
left there's bear hello hello how's it
going bear great how are you guys we are
very happy that you've decided to come
into the friendship I am thrilled
there's no other onion I would rather be
at right the best onion
that is the best the only onion that
won't make you cry hopefully bear and
we're all big funds for for many reasons
a lot of the people that listen to the
Friendship onion will of course know you
from um the the new Lord of the Rings on
TV but
um of course there is many many things
uh that you have done and if you don't
mind we'd like to embarrass you by
listing a few just now hold on let me
prepare myself just enjoy this I am
ready Dominic would you like to I just
got I can't read you know oh well I'll
go ahead then
um
are you ready an American musician and
composer of film television and video
games uh based in Los Angeles California
uh included in his Works get ready for
this people
Battlestar Galactica classic what an
absolute Beauty so there we are an
absolute classic Agents of Shield oh yes
oh
yes The Walking Dead fantastic the rings
of power of course and a video games
Call of Duty Vanguard God of War I mean
it just goes on and on Godzilla I mean
you've got enemies
the demons I mean we won't go through it
but gee you have embarrassed me enough
yeah I think that is absolutely plenty
but
um going back to a Battlestar Galactica
I think that's where I first uh got
introduced to your work that's where
everyone that so I got introduced to my
work that was my first job
I was 24.
um I was a child basically and uh should
never have been put in charge of a score
like Battlestar Galactica but there it
was well we'll go back to that then they
are just to start with I mean how how
would you how would that I mean who as
you say if that's your first job yeah
who said to you this is the guy
well I was
um uh working for a composer named
Richard Gibbs who scored the miniseries
and I was working under him the mini
series was a four-hour pilot basically
and so from there when it became a
series
um he Richard at the time was doing a
lot of feature films and and also
television at that time wasn't what it
is today so I think that there was a um
a sense that you know he he went on to
do these other things and I think that
they were looking for someone else to
take over to to score the show and uh
while they were looking they let me do
one episode oh nice and uh and that
episode was the the first episode that
aired one called 33
um which is in my
humble opinion one of the best hours of
television made in that decade it was I
mean the mini series was spectacular but
that first episode of season one of
Battle Star really shook things up and
showed that this was a series that was
not going to turn into a procedural
adventure of the week that it was going
to tell a a gripping story that unfolded
over seasons and um I didn't screw it up
you guys I didn't screw it up and at the
end they said uh okay I want to come in
tomorrow let's let's take a look at the
next episode and I thought ooh maybe I
get to do two episodes yeah here we go
and the rest was uh was history we just
kept going how many episodes in that
first season there were 13 and I ended
up scoring between the straight to DVD
movies and the shows and I did the
spin-off Capricorn I mean I ended up
scoring about 100 hours of Battlestar
Galactica wow you know over the course
of hours of Music you've not spent 100
hours doing anything I'm not sitting on
your house I've spent a lot over sitting
in March thinking about things well then
you're as good at that yeah you know
what I mean you've you've mastered
sitting on your ass thinking about stuff
and what would be
like looking back on Battlestar
Galactica now what would be the kind of
signature of that of that sound for you
it's an interesting question Dominic
because I I feel like I'm inside my head
and I don't know how to say what the
signature sound is because it's
something that I feel like an outside
Observer was like oh here's this thing
you do and I'd be very interested to
know I will say that when I look back on
what I did and listen uh which I do once
in a while
um I think that it was my naivete that
was on display in a really good way I
grew up loving film music
I did not grow up loving TV I mean I
watched a team and Magnum PI and stuff
but I wasn't like thinking this is where
I wanted my life direction to be I was
watching Star Wars it was watching Conan
the Barbarian and aliens and Highlander
and these kind of big Epic Fantasy
sci-fi stories so when I got the
opportunity to do Battlestar
um I was very young and I was energetic
enough and eager enough that I just
thought I'm gonna score this using all
the techniques that I've learned
studying that kind of music I'm not
gonna go ask someone who has experience
in TV how to do it
um I think you can hear that that I
didn't know what I was doing I just know
the kind of music I love to do and in a
way I have never asked anyone how to do
television I just kind of stumbled into
that way of doing it and and in a way
that kind of laid the groundwork for
what I would end up being asked to do on
rings of power 20 years later brilliant
well as you see I mean you you can tell
that those sort of
beggar movies as sort of where your
influences come from especially like
when you when I think of Battlestar I
think of it as being like an opera and
it's yeah and it's it's big and it's got
big themes and it has this always
underlying kind of
and I don't know like the end's not
going to be great like you know they're
coding yes yeah
they're working off you know every time
someone dies there's another human gone
kind of thing and that the music had
that operatic beautiful that supported
that story which uh was brilliant so
what a great well everyone on the show
felt the same way I did that it was
something really special and and Eddie
almost Edward James almost would often
pull us aside he was very much the
patriarch on set that you would assume
he is
um and he would always say you guys have
no idea you guys have no idea how
special this is talking to me and many
of the cast members for whom we were all
in our early 20s like we didn't know you
know and uh but he was right it's not
always like that yeah and and I'm sure
you guys can relate to that feeling of
getting involved in something early in
your career and you know yo this is
really special this is really good but
then there's somebody else in your life
that's like you're gonna go through the
rest of your life and probably never
work on something like this again it's
so rare so that was really cool and that
operatic quality that big sound is
something that evolved naturally and and
I would just again in my naivete I'd see
the season one finale and I just think
we didn't have an orchestra it wasn't
always a big sound
um and I went to the studio I just I
very naively called my friend at the
studio I didn't even call the
showrunners and I was like hey man like
have you seen the season finale I'm
crying like we got to get strings on
this we gotta have an orchestra and he's
like I know we have to do it and it's
like we found the money and just did it
you know what I mean like it was I was
contractually obligated to not use
Orchestra but I didn't know or care I
just saw that that ending I don't want
to spoil it the first season ending oh
my God and everybody on the show just
knew yeah we gotta we gotta have an
orchestra on this and that naivete did
sort of set in motion in my way of
approaching TV in that cinematic way
which is like let's just look at it and
and if no matter what it needs no matter
how ambitious it is let's just go for
that you know like that's what it should
be and I think that that is very much
the way TV's done now lost also was done
that way there were some other shows
around that time
um but shortly before that TV was
expected to be a small low budget
experience that does not replicate The
Cinematic experience and you know almost
it's almost switched now hasn't it TV it
really has it is not lost upon me
gentlemen that after Battle Star and
Walking Dead and Outlander over the last
10 years of my career I've made a
concerted effort to move into other
mediums I felt like I had done what TV
could do at the time and and I worked on
Godzilla king of the monsters moving
into movies I worked on little art films
like the professor and the madman I did
video games but that whole time
television was continuing to evolve in
the way that it had started in the
mid-2000s and sure enough when
when rings of power was announced
even then I started thinking like is
this show
going to be bigger and more Grand than
anything a film could even do today in
the modern era like are we at that
Tipping Point look bias is on the table
now that I work on it
I think it is do you know what I mean I
think that I think that we are at this
point where it has flipped and that
television for a variety of reasons
um is telling the kind of stories that I
grew up on that's that's the irony of it
right that like I grew up admiring all
these big epic movies and not really
thinking about television but in a way
if I were a child today the things that
would really be inspiring me and I'd be
obsessing over would be on TV yeah and
that movies would be the occasional
distraction or an occasional good one
would come up yeah is that weird well I
think it's an accurate way of describing
both those mediums now because like
television
affords you the time to spend with those
characters that you just do not have in
movies anymore you know they're in most
successful movies they're going to need
to present the character and what that
person is all about within the first
kind of six to eight minutes whereas in
rings of power you get over a couple of
hours yeah you know
Reserve Bar is your online source for
premium and luxury Spirits Wayne and
champagne and now Reserve Bar offer same
day delivery fantastic yeah Reserve Bar
has a vast lineup of rare and hard to
find bottles premium Brands celebrity
spirits and limited releases that you
won't find in your local store no one
does Spirits gifting better than Reserve
Bar if you're looking for an elevated
gift reservebar.com has you covered and
you can have that gift delivered right
to your door even better turn that
spirit's gift into a cherished Memento
with custom engraving perfect for
birthdays weddings anniversaries
Father's Day Mother's Day you name it
getting into home bartending fantastic
Reserve Bar has everything you need
Spirits for the shelves sure but they
also have every bar where tool and glass
you'll need Reserve Bar has a great
feature called cocktail lounge now this
is a treasure Trove of cocktail recipes
bartending tips interviews with Master
distillers celebrities and more the hot
Trend in spirits is ready to drink
cocktails have you tried them done I
have the Fantastic delicious they taste
better than ever and Reserve Bar now has
a huge collection of them these canned
cocktails are great for parties and if
you don't have time to tend the bar and
they're ideal for tailgating season
which is already in full swing dogs
reservebar.com also has barware
glassware cocktail recipes and more need
something for a party tonight Reserve
Bar no offers same day delivery straight
to your door
did you forget someone's birthday gift
well Reserve Bar to the rescue with same
day delivery well that's what I like
about it the most you know if you're
having an impromptu party maybe you
don't have time to go down to the
supermarket you've got enough things to
do maybe you're cooking some food you've
got guests showing up you do the same
day delivery everything shows up not
only the drinks the glassware they'll
bring ice for you every single thing you
need Reserve bars got you covered visit
reservebar.com today and use promo code
onion to save ten dollars off your
purchase of 75 or more on Spirits Wayne
or pre-made cocktails but only when you
use our special offer at reservebar.com
with the code onion that's
reservebar.com and code onion this offer
expires December 31st 2022.
Dom after years of fine print contracts
and getting ripped off by the big
Wireless providers if we've learned
anything is that there's always a catch
so when I first heard that mint mobile
offers premium Wireless starting at just
15 bucks a month I thought what's the
catch but after talking to them all made
sense there isn't one mint mobile secret
sauce is that they are the first company
to sell Wireless
online only they cut out the cost of the
retail stores and they pass all those
sweet savings directly onto you for
anyone who hates their phone bill mint
mobile offers premium Wireless for just
15 bucks a month mint mobile gives you
the best rates whether you're buying
just for you or for your family and at
mint family start at two lines all plans
come with unlimited talk and text plus
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network use your own
phone with any mint Mobile plan and keep
your same phone number along with all
your existing contacts were fantastic
switch to Mint mobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month to get your new Wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month and get
the plan shipped to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com
that's mintmobile.com
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com
I think there's also something to be
said for taking risks and when I think
about all the things that I love I mean
I guess I was going to say I I love
those those films when I was a kid that
took the risks
um and the copycats might be fun but
they're never as fun
and I definitely think that risks in
television
have been greater over the last 15 years
creative risks yeah you know and and
that as a viewer is almost where you're
more likely to see something that really
surprises you not exclusively obviously
no you can name five or six movies that
have come out of the last few years that
really took risks and were rewarded but
those are the those are the exceptions
that prove the rule you know where
whereas I think it used to be film
there there was always something new
coming out it was almost expected that
every summer some new movie would come
out and blow your mind you know I saw
something with that I think it was yeah
Matt Damon who was talking about that
and saying it's because of the way
movies are released now because it used
to be you'd have your your your your
theatrical release and then the DVD
release was basically the same as the
theatrical yeah so if you if if you made
a you know if it was a moving it cost
100 million and you got 50 million at
the theater you knew you would get 50
million and DVD and then it would it's
paid itself off and then you can start
making money and then you'd have a third
one with syndication television
broadcast yes and then you can maybe
make some profit there if it went well
there and there but that whole DVD thing
is disappeared now absolutely so now no
one will take the risk because you've
got a risky movie that costs 100 million
and the 50 million you make that's it
you kind of have a weekend that's crazy
it's a high stakes
um environment and uh but look I mean
that's happening in TV I don't want to
describe TV as this Shangri-La where
everyone takes risks and the money
doesn't matter because everything that
happened in feature film world is
happening in the video game space and
it's happening in TV where in order to
stand out you have to spend more money
the more money you spend the greater
risk you're taking yeah I mean and look
with
with rings of power I think
I mean I could talk all day about how
great I think the show is which is good
but it also is they are spending an
amount of money that will change the
history of the medium yeah one way or
the other no I'm not advocating one or
the other that's either going to be a
one-off and no one else ever tries it or
it'll become the standard in which case
if you aren't spending Amazon money to
make your show you're kind of doomed and
then television becomes exactly what
Matt Damon was describing yeah features
were it's a weird it's a weird situation
and it's almost like the best place to
be is right when a medium is exploding
outward yeah before all the money
catches up and then people get
risk-averse because as as true no matter
what you think of ring to power and I I
really like it I think it's fantastic I
think what you're talking about is true
when I said and I see me watch it on a
Sunday I think and um I sit there
and and it's a kind of an it's an
experience that I'm not getting with a
lot of other TV shows where I'm I'm in
Moria and I'm loving it and it's huge as
we were talking about before Dom and
these elevators going up Maria and I'm
just like oh wow and then I'm on a boat
yeah it looks amazing in the middle of
the sea heading for the Elven lands and
that it's an experience that I don't
feel like I've maybe got before watching
a TV or maybe seen it in a in a movie
theater before and the music and and
sometimes uh bear was stupid enough to
give him his uh telephone number so
sometimes I'll text him little things as
I'm watching it as well like oh I love
you from that I love your commentary man
it's always oh it's always pretty
awesome but yeah you know there's
something very special about that
experience and and you know and
people can be trolls online or whatever
but that experience of sitting in your
front room
uh watching on a TV I don't I'm trying
to think in my mind just now I don't
think I've had that before what do you
think Dominic have you seen the show
yeah yeah I love it it's great I agree
with Billy I think the immersion but
also like
like let's say they let's say Amazon
said we're gonna each week we're gonna
allow you to go see that at a cinema
which would be great because you'd have
a phenomenal sound and a great screen to
watch it on yeah but I think most people
nowadays have pretty good TVs and you
can say at home
comfortable with your doggy work yeah
yeah cup of tea yeah little snack
there's something quite cozy and
intimate about that and even though
there are moments of high excitement and
and uh you know kind of you know
characters ultimately being in in danger
there is a coziness about that world
yeah yeah I'm kind of yeah I'm kind of
working out as we're talking just now
yeah and it is a cinematic experience
but done in a way where yeah it's
comfortable and you're in your house and
I wonder if it's more comfortable for us
specifically because we have actually
been to those places and it it triggers
those parts of our amygdala absolutely
wow New Zealand and the crew and the
cast and everything you know for us it's
quite a person I was seeing that to Doma
yeah a couple of minutes ago like seeing
uh characters that kind of pop up in
Lord of the Rings in the rings of power
and seeing their story before that is
and even like what
I text bear last week like my throat
yeah I mean there's things like that is
just like so exciting It's gotta be a
trip for you guys yeah I was just this
morning
zooming uh with Megan Richards who plays
poppy on the show talking about the
harfoot song yeah and I was telling her
for a minute that I was I was realizing
like
I'm gonna hang out today with the two
people who have sung Hobbit songs in
live action adaptation yeah like because
I was suddenly realizing like I want to
see Billy in a few hours yeah how
surreal but then I also realized like
how cool for her to get to pick up a
tradition
I mean can you even call it a tradition
I get but it's like you know the the the
song in Return of the King that you sang
is such an iconic thing people remember
and now here's a new Hobbit character
singing song like what was that like for
you to see that I mean as as I've told
the story a few times you know we're not
when I wrote that song I wanted it to
sound like it's something these grand
mother had sung because she had her
grandfather sing it so it could have
been the hard films that could have came
from them so when I heard that song I
was like oh it's great the whole bit I'm
calling them the hobbits you can call
them the hobbits they're singing in
Middle Earth and I love that it was
great Bears uh I I felt the same and I I
I felt that it was like
I feel it as a comfort thing too I mean
obviously the movies for me were
something I experienced when they were
done
over and over
and over along with all the behind the
scenes DVDs uh the the all the
supplemental material that that was made
about what you guys went through
I mean
so I felt that same sense of coming home
when I watched the show it is
interesting to imagine that I mean I'm
also trying to do my part as a filmmaker
to welcome people to Middle Earth that
don't feel that way yeah you know what I
mean and that's one thing that like
I am reminded uh in all fan interactions
many of which they're all intense most
are good uh some aren't but it's still
like
there's a whole other demographic of
planet Earth people that are younger
than me that that don't feel anything
about Lord of the Rings that this will
be their way in yeah you know what I
mean so it's like trying to be mindful
of like
welcoming back
people that loved those movies to Middle
Earth but but also we're also saying to
younger people go check out those movies
and do you know what I mean and
that universally I know that I spoke to
uh Pete Jackson when he was making The
Hobbit and he was saying exactly the
same thing he says a lot of people will
be watching these Hobbit movies as their
introduction yeah and then they'll see
Lord of the Rings so now there's the
rings of power that might be the first
thing that might lead to The Hobbit that
might lead to yeah
well it all goes back to the books
that's incredible that's what I love
about it is that ultimately it's
all of this is based on this incredible
Source material you know I I read The
Hobbit when I was a kid
but it was the movies that drove me to
the books it was the movies that made me
re-evaluate and think I must have missed
something because I'm a very visual
um person like film was my passion and
the animated various animated Lord of
the Rings things they were cool but man
for me it was like Star Wars and Conan
the Barbarian in Jurassic Park like yeah
I'm I am I am not of the generation that
like Ralph bakshi's Lord of the Rings
could compete with that so I just kind
of wrote it off do you know what I mean
and then when the movies came out I
thought I gotta go back I obviously you
know missed something so did you stumble
into that first Fellowship of the Ring
movie thinking at that point it was kind
of a successful film and and your
friends and family had seen it or what
made you go no I was preaching that this
movie was going to be the greatest movie
of all time before it came out and I'll
tell you why Peter Jackson
I had adored his films through the 90s I
rented Dead Alive that which brain dead
yeah you know that poster the the the
VHS box I was like what is this a scary
person holy [ __ ] that movie was amazing
can I say holy [ __ ] yeah holy [ __ ] that
movie is amazing uh and I and at that
same time you know I I loved cult
filmmakers I loved Sam Raimi I loved
that kind of
storytelling and I was like this guy
Peter Jackson is a genius and then I saw
Heavenly Creatures and and then I saw
The Frighteners which is hands down the
most underrated Studio feature film of
all time yeah that movie blew my mind so
then when I thought when I heard that
guy
is doing a big fantasy movie that alone
I was like oh this is gonna be amazing
do you know what I mean and and it was
and I felt so validated uh but not
surprised at all
um because I just thought you know he
and Sam Rainey were just these two guys
that I was telling everybody you got to
keep an eye on these filmmakers man and
boy 2001 and 2002 I felt I was probably
annoying all my friends between that and
when Spider-Man came out I was like you
see
yeah I told you you got to listen to me
yeah also in in rings of power to go
back to that for a second Howard Shaw
wrote the original title theme yeah so
did you spend some time with Howard as
collaborators together I did and I
didn't I I got to know him and speak
with him a few times we did not get to
collaborate right uh because of the
timing of the schedule I started and
then he did his main title six months
later like I knew it was coming
but it but it wasn't something that I
was gonna hear before I was basically
done laying out all the themes and well
into um episode six
um but I
I was given free reign to do whatever I
wanted and what I wanted was to honor
what he did and continue in the sort of
like tradition that he set out and so it
was fantastic to hear his demo when it
came in uh which kind of it was spine
tingling hearing it but also getting to
talk with him and I spoke with him
several times and he was supportive and
generous with his time and and
um ultimately it was wonderful to sort
of
exchange words with him about writing
about our creative process our creative
lives that alone
was amazing but then to get to talk with
him about Lord of the Rings specifically
was double amazing but then to get to
talk with him about her creative process
on Lord of the Rings because I am
scoring the new Lord of the Rings is
like mind-blowing yeah yeah amazing so
that was really cool you know what I
mean I feel um I felt
a lot of support from him and a sort of
unspoken
um
passing of the torch like like I'm doing
my thing and we're we're entering the
second age through this lens that
connects to the movies but after that
it's like you got this you know what I
mean how did it how did it feel like
you're you're
is then sitting there in front of a
piano or something and going okay I know
this is going to be like all right man
I'm gonna confess that like I talked
about my naivete when I did Battlestar
Galactica I I retain it to this day my
my ability to just be naively excited
about whatever I'm doing right gets me
through the day because can you imagine
like if I woke up and went okay today
I'm gonna have to write a piece of music
that will be as famous as Howard Shores
Shire theme that would be scrutinized by
a hundred million fans I would curl up
under the covers in the trolliest period
of History the humanity oh my God I mean
or to Seattle I mean to even sit at the
computer in front of the piano I
wouldn't even get to the piano I would
just be weeping uh in bed so do you so
like I don't think of that so you can't
think no I get up and I go ah man I get
to tell this awesome story so like not
even talking about everything else
you've done for rings of power do you
write anything before you see a picture
or do you wait for them to send you some
pictures uh some uh to little column A
and A little column b i
watched a rough cut of two episodes then
I read the scripts spoke with the
showrunners then I didn't look at
footage again for almost two months
right and I also told them I I wouldn't
speak to them for two months right I was
like you're not gonna hear anything
you're not going to hear from me
bye bye right I need to go into my space
where I am safe to mess around and I'm
gonna write a bunch of themes because
it's you you need themes I need themes
to write anything but in particular I
think to write something for Lord of the
Rings you need themes yeah and you need
so many different worlds yeah abilities
yeah you need to have themes that
connect to those different societies and
then within those societies you have
conflicting themes that each have to be
different but enough that you understand
oh these are two dwarf characters that
are in conflict with one another these
are two elf characters these are two
human characters
um
and I you know created this whole kind
of rule set and and mapped out intervals
and colors and rhythms because I just so
desperately wanted to make themes that
stood on their own and could be
identified quickly
and then I looked at the footage again
and started splashing some music onto
some scenes and then I sent those scenes
to the showrunners they never heard the
themes in isolation they heard the
themes in isolation when the record came
out okay otherwise uh because I put some
tracks on the record otherwise I I just
let them watch the scenes because I
didn't want to ruin their ability to
have the same experience you guys had if
if the Kaza Doom theme works you should
just be able to show you that scene and
you get it yeah and it's great you
you've done such a wonderful job man I
think it really is it's wonderful such
an imposing world to jump into
um but yeah it's fantastic and it's it's
so funny because I mean I'm sure we've
all seen it if you if you watch those
incredible projects that are defined by
the schools and they take the score out
what is that like Star Wars without the
school it's amazing there's something so
strange about obviously Jaws without the
school
and then and the Pete Jackson Lord of
the Rings uh film that we did without
the score I'm sure would be just like
rings of power there's there's so much
that you can put into the thing that I I
agree and the thing that I learned
when I transitioned from being just
a fan of all these things to wanting to
do all these things because I wanted to
do this when I was five years old and I
started writing music every day when I
was 13 years old so really I mean I'm 43
I've been doing this for 30 years but
one of the things I learned is that
there the sum total of everybody's Work
Director acting writing editing sound
design music
creates this thing that we as consumers
as fans it's very easy to worship these
things and and and it's fun and you want
to but they're all made by just people
that step up to the plate and bring to
the project what they had to bring that
day that's all it is yeah you know what
I mean you hear like
Jerry Goldsmith's score for Chinatown
that lonely uh trumpet solo he had two
weeks to do the entire score he got
hired at the last minute he's like oh
[ __ ] it's a all right a Noir I'm just
gonna write the score to Chinatown he
just did it and then he moved on yeah
you know what I mean and and in a way
that's I I actually haven't even thought
about verbalizing it this way before I
think in starting to realize that I
internalized that that
I give myself permission to write the
worst music ever heard by humans I'm
just gonna get I just gotta write some
music today I'm gonna get out of bed and
write some music not only am I not
aspiring to be as good as Howard Shore
like I'm just aspiring to be just
garbage right if I can just sit here and
just write this something terrible that
gets me out of bed and gets me going and
then I start playing around with it and
it you have to just get those shackles
that self-censorship I am I imagine
correct me if I'm wrong that as actors
there must be a similar thing where you
must be unafraid to make a complete ass
of yourself in order to find right yeah
yeah absolutely there's definitely times
with directors where the director will
say we got it and we might say can I
just try something it's probably not
going to be great but can you just try
something and and very often it won't be
great sometimes you'll catch something
but yeah you have to be in a place of
being able to I think it's make a mess I
think it's interesting because to
actually I think we all like to be cool
and people think we're cool
but the life of an artist is so
vulnerable like we we really have to be
boldly unafraid to just look like a
complete idiot yeah and and that kind of
safe place that you can sit and is so
comfortable that you can do that
sometimes and there's nothing better as
an actor I think than when you get a
character that someone explained it once
to me and I thought it was brilliant he
said will you burst the bubble yeah and
then you threw that sort of little cage
you put yourself in the little bubble
and then you you kind of you're just
living as that character in that place
and that is the greatest and you can see
it when I was just watching um the first
Austin Powers movie yeah and you can
tell Mike Myers did that on that where
he just like got a character that yeah
you could say anything to him and he
could riff he was there he was in that
world and it's just the best and it must
be like that with music as well it's
very similar and I'm
I am I've been doing this long enough
now and I'm I'm confident enough that
I'm up front when people hire me where I
say I'm gonna try to scare you with my
first ideas
do not
fire me but I my job here is to come at
you with something that is uncomfortable
pushes your buttons yeah it's just
splashing canvas yeah we'll try a bunch
of different things but if I come out of
the gate right away with something
that's safe and conservative and what is
to be expected of the genre
then we're dooming ourselves to
something that's ordinary yeah and you
can always tell when someone goes like
oh yeah do that or sometimes they're
like I don't know you know
um and the rings of Power Team were they
were all great
um they were they were all fantastic and
even as I even as I described
some of my ideas
um the numenor theme in particular is
outside of the palette
of Howard Shore I I perhaps foolishly
expressed my enthusiasm for bringing in
Middle Eastern instruments so that it
felt
Egyptian and Babylonian and Mesopotamian
maybe some ancient Greece and then I
realized too late that it's like uh oh I
am scaring people and and one of the
show owners said I don't I don't know
and I said
I understand this is scary and I want
you to trust me that if I write this and
you don't like it it's not going in your
show fear not but you gotta let me do it
and he was like
okay yeah you got to be able to do those
big swings you know yeah I just think
what makes him a TV and film even harder
I think for musicians is they put these
uh temps on doing the temp music and
then the director the show run or
Whatever Gets
used to hearing the temp music
just for anybody that doesn't know what
it is is like scores or songs from other
sources that are placed temporarily into
the edit just to see if the edit works
and to be able to screen it for people
yeah
um but it can create a Groove in your
mind I've seen a lot together yeah where
they're just like uh just just do
something like the temp and it's like
it's Braveheart or something yeah it it
is
a reality of of how film and television
are made and sometimes you know aspiring
composers will come out to me and
that'll be a question what do you what
do you do when a director is like that's
all they want is this you know please
they're like imploring me what are your
secrets and I and I always say the same
thing well you give them the temp and
hope that your next job is better I I
learned a trick from my my mentor
who was uh one of the great Legends of
film music Elmer Bernstein he scored the
Ten Commandments The Great Escape uh The
Magnificent Seven To Kill a Mockingbird
Ghostbusters Animal House
um Age of Innocence Cape Fear with
Martin Scorsese he he had a he had a
long career and he taught me when when I
was young
there's only one question you ever need
to ask a filmmaker and I use this almost
every day to this day
because he says
never let them talk about music don't
ever talk to them about music in a in a
well no actually in any in any situation
he says all you need to ask them is
what do you want the audience to feel
that question bypasses all of the things
that are in the way of the core truth
any director whether they are brilliant
or completely amateur has an answer for
that question yes at any frame of their
footage yeah that's what the director's
language is right that's literally they
are the Avatar and the advocate for the
audience at any time they can say that
and when you bypass all the other
linguistic yeah Road bumps about music
and you say what do you want the
audience to feel yeah the truth comes
out and then you can go I got you yeah
you can speak the same language at that
point right I'm a translator ultimately
my job is to talk film with a filmmaker
and then go like turn it into music and
send it back and say did I translate
this correctly you know so well for you
uh the kind of standout schools in movie
history well the ones that you always
come back to that Masterpiece I mean I I
mentioned one already I think Elmer
Bernstein's To Kill a Mockingbird is so
timeless it was written at a time when
film music in the 50s
film music before the 50s was Western
classical music I love uh King Kong and
all these other you know all these like
um max Steiner scores and and uh and and
yet it all sounded like bombastic
classical western music and even to a
degree like
should King Kong sound like bombastic
Western orchestral music I don't know
that was the norm in the 50s that
started to change there are so many
great film scores but I mean I I guess
are you asking which ones are my
personal faves yeah personal is always
the best because there's obviously
there's ones across the board that
everyone will agree of like like
obviously Jaws is a standout one for
most people yeah but as someone who
actually works in the business what are
the ones that continue to move you know
the ones that uh um Conan the Barbarian
by basil polidoris is just a master
class in Epic writing and uh doesn't
ever get enough praise you know for for
how amazing it is
um and uh I mean there's so many like
Jerry Goldsmith's um Star Trek the
motion picture is another one that gets
sort of Lost in the
in the main title that became Star Trek
the Next Generation it just sort of
feels like oh that's that's Star Trek
it's no at the time that was this weird
Robert Wise movie that got green lit
because of Star Wars but it's nothing
like Star Wars and and some of the
themes in it are so just crushingly
gorgeous they have no right to be that
gorgeous it says you know I mean
enyamorakone my God Cinema Paradiso and
the mission I mean his work in the in
the 80s that was enyo kind of like he
had done like 200 Spaghetti Westerns and
I mean he was still at his Peak just
like riding loop-de-loops around
everybody else The Untouchables is
another one but you know what I mean
like when you say any moricone people
think
and to be fair that's amazing if he only
wrote that he's in the film score Hall
of Fame forever yeah the mission is one
of the reasons the mission oh my God and
it's like the movie's not even that
great yeah it's good but that score my
God the way he took the like he took
these South American Children's Choir
and the oboe that the Jeremy Irons
character played right it was like the
oboe soars over this melody with the
with the South American like indigenous
percussion it's just like a master class
yeah do that you know we had we had
Chiquito on I'm sure you know jakina of
course yeah
um I was lucky enough to wear with them
on last and um so we we had him on and
we were asking him about how he came up
with that
kind of iconic theme now from up from
Pixar's Up and he said that he was just
humming in the shower one day remember
yeah yeah he woke up with it and then he
was like I'm not sure what that is where
it's come from let's see if it hangs
around and then he said he got in the
shower and it was still hanging around
and then he thought I'm gonna have to
find out if that is someone else's and
then realized that it wasn't someone
else's and then became this what one of
the most standout kind of Melodies From
Pixar Canon oh yeah absolutely and I I
love knowing he has that same he must
have that same insecurity I have which
is when you get a great idea you're like
well this has got to be somebody else
right right there's no way
someone to time must have thought of
putting these six together I know yeah
well that's like McCartney with uh with
yesterday right I mean he he was walking
around for months um singing this song
called scrambled eggs that he thought
well this this can't be an original this
must be someone else's and then sooner
or later everyone was like no we've
never heard that before and then it
became yesterday today so wild amazing
if we can jump back to another one of my
favorites of yours in a one that you
know for me could have went really wrong
as a Outlander because talk to me as a
Scott about how wrong that could have
gone but surely you must be a bit of a
Scott yourself McCreery I am indeed
the McCreery side of the family where is
your family from
um I think they go back to Ireland
um but the mccreerys have been in
America uh since the 1880s
in the American South
um and the other side of my family is
Armenian uh and actually my Battle Star
days I I wrote for Armenian duduke the
calpakian side of my family escaped the
genocide and came through Ellis Island
in the 20s right
um The Armenian duduke and the bagpipes
were were both appear early on in
Battlestar Galactica season one as my
little DNA thumbprint I love it but I
grew up I grew up loving Celtic music
and I always went to the Highland Games
there was a Highland Games near
Bellingham Washington where I grew up
and I would just go there and I would
hear there'd be like 40 bagpipe bands in
competition so the Drone it's like you
know acres and Acres of bagpipe bands
all droning on that B flat and you're
just like I would go to bed at night
with the Drone stuck in my head and I
even in the morning I'd wake up and I
don't have perfect pitch but I go is
that B flat still I had to go down the
piano there it is because you hear it
for so long that might drive some one
else insane I'm in my happy place man
watching people doing the folk dances
and the caber toss
so that part of my DNA has always been
something that has sparked my musical
interests and that I think was a reason
that Ron Moore hired me on Outlander but
I was nervous
about how the show would be perceived
um by Scottish people I mean it's
written by a woman from Arizona do you
know what I mean like it it I I
completely understand any skepticism
about Americans telling this story
um
how I mean what did you think of it well
for me before you were on it needless to
say what was your first impression well
I I I kind of always worry when uh
people take Scottish sort of culture and
especially when it's sort of historical
and oh this is just going to go down
that sort of shortbread tin sort of you
know fancy little kids remember did you
see the old Disney movie Rob Roy the
Highland Rogue exactly or and then Darby
O'Gill and the little people Sean
Connery's first movie yes he's like old
depictions of like I remember the The
Ice I dug up the Rob Roy movie
um after I saw the the Liam Neeson one
which I thought was [ __ ] awesome if I
may say that yeah but it was like Rob
Roy is like an Henry Nave like it's so
oh it's you realize like and and I you
know the griege the artist I work with
sometimes on Scotland on things in
Outlander he sings the main title you
know I I've learned a lot from him just
about I think he bristles at that in a
way that as an American I started to
Intuit like
that's kind of a shitty depiction but I
think correct me if I'm wrong I mean is
that something that that you always felt
was unfair yeah there is a sort of it's
when it becomes too simplified doesn't
it in two sort of cleaned up like the
music a little even back when I was
growing up there was um there was a show
called thingamajig yeah and they play
these kind of Scottish and and
everybody's saying what the hell
and it was just it used to be great
because you know we'd have parties at
home where people would sing real Gaelic
and real Celtic songs and it was magic
it was real and it was about real things
and Robert Burns and it was brilliant
and I was so glad when I heard your
music from the show that you you got
that you know you've got 100 Scotland by
the bowl 100 what I was going for you
know what I mean it was real people
singing about real things and real
relationships but I do want to thank you
for getting the music right oh man that
means the world and I like that's right
I was wondering if people in Scotland
McCrary yeah
while we continue to talk about music
should we should we eat the world or we
should we always eat the world delicious
because we do like to eat we're Hobbits
after all Billy and Dom eat the world
did you bring this in there or did you
see you guys are gonna surprise me okay
so we're going to be in a a lovely treat
from Israel and is this is this then
afternoon tea this is dinner this would
be afternoon this is afternoon tea time
here comes Eddie Here Comes Eddie and
all eyes that are on them I'll read a
little blurb here while Eddie tell me
thank you what we're going to be uh
trying here thank you very much there oh
thanks Eddie it's called the Bamba
peanut butter snack Bamber is a snack
made of peanut butter flavored puffed
Maize manufactured
manufactured in Israel Bamba is one of
the leading snack foods produced in
southern Israel thanks Eddie oh it's
been marked it's in night thank you
since 1964 with no decline in sales it
says this might come directly from Bamba
um Bamba makes up for 25 of the Israel
snack Market similar products from other
domestic manufacturers include the
butterfly the shush it's also named the
Bamba snack because it sounds like baby
talk what sounds like baby
it's made from peanut butter flavored
puff maze contains no preservatives or
food coloring and is enriched with
several vitamins but it does contain
high amounts what was that wait what was
the first thing peanut butter flavored
puffed maze puffed maze I guess the
energy content is 160 calories per 28
grams which is a lot because these weigh
light as air Bamber is certified kosher
by the badats Jerusalem The Washington
Post described it as cheese Doodles
without the cheese William should we
give it a go so this is very pop in
Israel if there's anyone out there in
Israel listening or watching to us hello
the listeners will send us these uh
ideas this is from a listener fantastic
have I go I've had these type of things
before I don't know if it was strictly
Bamba but lovely that's fascinating
because the texture makes me think I'm
eating a cheese puff yeah I've never
tasted on a what's it as we would call
it in the UK but it's peanut buttery
it's overwhelmingly peanut butter
extremely I don't normally like being a
bar unless it's actually peanut butter I
don't think like things you don't like
peanut butter flavored things no let's
explore this you're not like a peanut a
Reese's Peanut Butter Cup no oh I do I
just like peanut butter how about
Reese's Pieces no yeah I like them too
do you know most people in England think
that you know because Reese's Pieces are
obviously put down for E.T to walk into
the house most people in Britain think
that they're M M's because we don't have
recent species or we didn't really we
didn't in the 80s we might now these are
lovely if you don't mind the same does
anyone mind me saying that I don't mind
you see him one day when I travel to
Israel I will be on the lookout
I'm going to continue here guys in the
advertising for the bamboo it says
Batman's advertising features the baby
band The Character heavily baby Bamber
uh Bamba is a cartoon character depicted
wearing a blue diaper or nappy he has
one tooth and he's bald except for one
Ginger girl in front of his head in
honor of international Women's Day 2020
a female baby bamboo was introduced the
female whip baby Bamber whereas a pink
T-shirt and has Pigtails in March 2021
the baseball team the New York Nets
announced its partnership with this
particular crisp wow you go New York
Mets I'll tell you what Dom a one belong
to Ram looking like the baby and you'll
need to look after me I'd love that one
just just one tooth no hair one there's
no hair I don't know how you're gonna
grow a ginger hair but you're working no
no I'm Scottish yeah every so often uh
Billy will grow just one single hair out
of the tip of his nose just like that
wow it goes quite long as well wow
no don't tell me it's amazing it's
amazing it will get long
um yeah for anyone who's just listening
bear McCreery has wonderful long hair
that's true I have you always had that I
started to grow it out about 20 years
ago and I've kept it at shoulder length
until about
2015 when I just
decided to never cut it again wow which
is funny because you know so many people
grew their hair out in the pandemic but
I had already
uh I had already done it
um and then when I was at the um
the rings of power Premiere only then I
feel so dumb confessing is only then did
I realize everyone wears wigs in the
show
everyone they have these incredible hair
pieces even you know actors I'm staring
at their face eight hours a day for a
year and then I'm looking around
something looking like I look like I'm
cosplaying
I know exactly like like it's like who's
this Fanboy over here that uh Hey
Aragorn you know these are fantastic
yeah I'm digging these now guys you
might be thinking out there the shape
the consistency the lightness how is
this thing manufactured could you tell
me should I tell you yeah corn grits are
popped under high pressure turning them
into long white lines of puffed
unflavored Bamba the lines are then cut
into nuggets and then moved to a drying
chamber where they are air baked this is
so appetizing 20 seconds 20 seconds just
plenty dollars gives them that lovely
crispy is it though yeah yeah the peanut
butter imported from Argentina it's
added at the end a worker stands on A
step above a rotating drum and pours a
picture of liquid peanut butter into
each container what's his name
hammerhock it's called Juan right carry
on as the drums turn the nuggets are
coated the hot band that is then moved
along a conveyor belt to cool before
packaging not after packaging because it
could damage the packets
stick to the sides brilliant there's a
little bit of information about that
yeah let's score them flavor out of ten
we score out of 10 here you can add a
decimal point if you'd like it could be
6.4 it could be 8.9 but the flavor has
to be out of 10. and while you're
thinking about that bear how many hours
have you written of music for the rings
of power I wrote nine hours of music for
eight hours of footage wow where's the
other over it's the themes all right
there we go yeah nine hours of music and
I did that in nine months wow
wow yeah that's that's an hour a month I
said nowhere a month what time how much
is that a day though
no look at the math look at his math
mind trying to work that out how can you
wear that out well see see let's say 30
days in a month yeah it's about it's
about 60 60 Minutes about two minutes
two minutes in an hour
I don't know
I'm not a musician
it is it is doable in that
it was done it was done uh it takes
longer than you would think wouldn't it
yeah when I when I did that song for The
Hobbit you know the the last goodbye I
went down in New Zealand I was supposed
to be there for like a week I was there
for about two months yeah saying things
back and forth it couldn't get him out
no I couldn't I was I got a hotel room
for free it was lovely amazing
um but I was just thinking there that
you know themes in the worlds and you're
talking about Howard Shore I remember
when I first sent that song to Howard
Shore I was shooting it you know that he
would just say this is awful that's
rubbish and he ruled he wrote back and
said they look he loved it he says but
there's no minor seventh chords in Lord
of the Rings and I was like I didn't
even know I was playing a menace there
was a couple on the guitar I had no idea
you put a minor hold on I can't believe
before I agreed to this interview I
didn't realize you put a minor I'm sorry
I'm sorry why was no one telling me this
this is outrageous
right now no no you can just leave oh my
God
awful the [ __ ] is wrong with
wrong I'm doing nowhere I'm just one I
bet it was over and over again I didn't
even know there was one in there you're
a description disgraceful utterly oh god
let's change the subject he's left us
like a stink in the air now all right
scores
I like this taste but I would give it a
slight critique here which is that I
want a little bit of salt I like the
peanut butter I want a little bit of
salt in my peanut butter so I'm going to
demote it by a point and I'm gonna give
it a seven would have given it an eight
with muscle
I used to grab your house Tom and you'd
have a jar of a peanut butter with uh
chilies in it yeah I made it myself and
then you just eat it by the Spoonful I
would dig out the peanut butter into a
bowl
mold and salt cayenne pepper paprika
chili flakes garam masala
black pepper
coconut oil mix it all up put it back in
the jar I lived on that but you also did
this because your friend only likes
peanut butter in butter form yeah that's
very thoughtful of you yeah yeah I'm
here for Billy I'd no like to change
that there because I love these things
yeah they're tasty these wow this is
changing your world view on Peanut
Butter what was the score then flavor um
I'm gonna give it I'm gonna give it an
eight and the reason I'm gonna give it
an eight is that
almost like like you were saying Dom I'm
so used to peanut butter being in
combination with other things I wish I
had some chocolate to wrap this around
like can you imagine like a malt ball
like if there was like chocolate
covering on this peanut butter light
fluffy thing um
all right the next category Aesthetics
how does it look how does it look what
do you think it looks a little bit like
a grub like a like a beetle lava yeah
somebody would eat in one of those like
survivor shows right or like packing
styrofoam packing styrofoam for sure
this is all quite negative the end of a
cigarette right what if someone loves
all those things we aren't saying we are
negative right okay I'm putting negative
colors yeah you're putting Vibes out I
feel bad about that though it's not the
most attractive chip I've ever seen but
yeah I like the slightly strangeness of
it I'm gonna give it a five I was gonna
say five okay I was going to say six oh
ever The Optimist yeah Oh Billy your
favorite category the final category is
usefulness how useful is this food
useful exactly yeah it's a break let me
see for instance you had friends coming
over they weren't invaded did you just
come through your house and you said oh
are you guys hungry and they went yeah
we are hungry and you went to your
cupboard and went to hear what's in it
yeah what have you got this week there's
two pounds of flour there's two packets
of these there's a couple eggs in the
fridge
some cream
two pints of milk and some uh hundreds
and thousands of toppings there's a lot
of dairy produce you have but that's all
you've got in the house is this could
you do something could you pre could you
make could you do oh the eggs I'm
wondering if there's a way to to powder
these into some sort of um
yeah with some scrambled eggs so you
sprinkled this on it I don't know are
they useful I don't know I can't think I
mean you Crump it's gonna crumble into a
powder but then what do you do with that
powder could you could you crumble that
onto popcorn or something not a bad idea
that's a nice idea I didn't see you had
popcorn oh yeah sorry I do at my house
all right
um that's the only thing that I can
because it's a Savory thing it's not
going to really go sweet is it no I said
well did you put it on a cake
oh nice could you crumble on the ice
cream
Could you actually use it as packing
peanuts could you yeah
egg or something really valuable put it
in a box you realize you don't have any
you've got to ship it out right away
I'll let you hear what happened to that
Brian I'm the FedEx man
so as shipping peanuts you're saying
it's quite useless it's not very fails
in this category it's zero would be
correct yeah okay but I've now made the
powder
so you can see what it's like yeah
versatile you gotta love you you know
what else I'm thinking hearing that on a
close mic yeah
ASMR you know like people like that
don't they
just enjoy this ladies and gentlemen
nice then there's a market for that yeah
it's nice that do that for 10 hours
people love that Although our listeners
don't we had to vote and they hate it
when we too close to the mic so I do
like 55 of them hated it that's a slim
majority 45 are okay with it
I'm gonna say in terms of
them
in terms of Versatility yeah how useful
it is I I'm gonna give it a two and a
half two and a half that's not very good
I'm I'm feeling very optimistic today
better you know it's nice having you in
the studio
I don't give a [ __ ] I love it I in fact
I want to play the baby and and the ads
yeah you can write the music for it or
write a new jingle yeah
it could be the baby I'm the baby
Billy boy the baby Bamba right there
that's fantastic
um I'm gonna give it six I think I could
find something yeah I could find
something to do with it you're the good
cop in this scenario I see bear what do
you think well I'm rubbing my breasts
don't vote on that vote on the snap
yeah yeah
no comment on that right although maybe
as like a massage tool like you could
crumple it up
it's exfoliant that's what it is yeah
I'm changing 97.5 there you go what do
you think bear I think it could work
massage it into the muscles give it give
it a score to attend then for me
usefulness well I wanted to ship my
Faberge Egg and I can't so it's zero so
it's absolutely zero that's not good
yeah it's dominant it can only do one
thing although I guess in your
hypothetical with the guests that came
over I would do a little omelet and use
it as garnish I guess yes
I mean a peanut butter omelette
I don't know but you did also say these
are people that I wasn't expecting or
didn't even want yeah come over so let's
if I don't want them to come over I
probably want them to leave yeah and
wait a minute so then then it's a 10.
perfect because then you bring it out I
would cover the omelette with this yeah
would you like a peanut butter
a peanut butter dust omelette yeah I'll
tell you what bear we could talk all day
with you it's great well should we
finish with a song knocking off any can
I ask one question all right because
there's something that we always like to
do because you know in case a listener
maybe a young listener is maybe thinking
about becoming a composer or
uh doing film music or TV music how did
you get from a 13 year old
in your room writing music every day to
being the guy that did
um Battlestar Galactica where what
happened in there that made that
possible yeah good question
um that is a good question I
love what I do yeah and I started doing
it all day every day and I when I was
about 13 realized that I I just wanted
to do it all the time and I would be
okay if I lived under a bridge if it
meant I got to write music and when I
got to college I just found people that
were doing student films
um anybody that had anything that needed
music I just I was thrilled to do it and
I built up a group of people that felt
the same way we had no money you know I
would I would scrounge together enough
money to get pizza for the orchestra
session so I would you know conduct my
score and also I would write for whoever
was available I called every musician I
knew and so if I was doing a student
film I'd go okay we got three clarinets
uh a snare drum and a cello so that's
what you're gonna get you know what I
mean
um and I just kept doing that and there
was a point early on on Battlestar in
the first season that I realized
that nothing had changed but I was
finally getting paid a little bit just a
little bit
um and that I was still just waking up
every day doing what I love to do
um and I think that then my actual like
no joke advice is
if you love what you do and that's why
you are collaborating with people people
want to work with you
they you want to be that type of person
that's excited and comes into the room
eager to contribute and and just excited
to get to do your part of it
and
if you are even you don't even have to
be talented the only thing you have to
do is work hard at it you know what I
mean the people that put in the work I
don't think I'm supremely talented oh
you are well uh
I think I put in a lot of hours let me
put it this way my my talent could
definitely be my work ethic you know
that I just put in the hours and I love
doing it and I feel like that benefited
me so much and I I still like to think
that I walk into any project like wow
this is cool let's do this you guys you
know what I mean yeah and sometimes I
sometimes I'm gonna make money sometimes
I I won't I you know I'm just gonna I'm
just here to like have fun doing what I
want to do and if I don't get to do that
I'll I'll go towards someone who will
let me do that
foreign
I think we don't you think if we've got
a musician with this do you think we
should end with a song so we we
sometimes well we often ask our guests
and sometimes they say no to suggest a
song that they think is funky now just
so everyone out there knows doesn't mean
it need to be funky in terms of like you
know Earth Wind and Fire funkyo Bobby
Womack funky sure is is does it move you
yes you know Mozart can be funky yeah
you know is it funky it can be funky did
it get you going did you did you feel
something did you get your juices going
listen to this do you want to introduce
this song to us and to our listeners uh
yeah uh so Billy texted me about this
and I thought like
this definition of funky
means that when you hear it you have to
stop what you're doing and the the music
just grabs hold of your body and you go
to another place and it takes you there
love it
um that's what that's what good music
does for me and there's so many pieces
of music
and uh uh it's actually one we've
already alluded to uh in our
conversation the peace that I thought of
was from Jerry Goldsmith's score to Star
Trek the motion picture
elia's theme which is so
beautiful it's so it has no reason to be
so beautiful and it's like Jerry
Goldsmith is just like writing circles
around what that character needs but
he's giving her all this depth and it's
not even a theme that would sort of go
on into I'm sorry am I getting too into
Star Trek you can never get to any stop
trading don't don't mess with me bro
honestly okay
because of the Star Trek poster up there
there you are yeah uh yeah so like to me
this is one of those like deep sort of
Space Nine yeah indeed it's base nine uh
it's not something that became part of
the popular lexicon of Star Trek the way
the main title did from that movie that
became this theme for TNG it's like this
it's almost like buried at the bottom of
Star Trek lore in between the original
series and The Wrath of Khan when the
only thing else was this weird movie
that is good or not I don't know but
that score is good and even buried in
that score is that theme that is just
crushingly gorgeous and when it when it
comes on if it comes on my um Spotify or
I'm walking on earbuds or or whatever
I'm doing I stop I have to stop what I'm
doing and like
just experience it very cool well Eddie
have you got that have you got elia's
theme yes sir
let's hear it let's have a listen
oh
Shelly start with the tune
ah
little quote of
the theme
but back to the good stuff
listen to The Counter line
moving up and down like a wave
[Music]
so did that end up becoming the theme
tune to the Next Generation no no no it
only exists in the movie so how does it
but it does there's a character named
Elia yeah is is in that movie why am I
will you tell us Billy you you well yeah
there was another there's another theme
in it uh which was the main theme that
then became you actually heard the horns
that's from this movie right it was one
of several themes that Goldsmith wrote
um that um but but it's that other one
elia's theme that's so
gorgeous I mean it's like my body tenses
up because like I can't even handle how
beautiful it is as in music weirdly
that's incredible because it's basically
four notes there yeah and it's just as
you say the counter Melodies is there
yeah just the way that it's the the
upper strings are floating up and down
and then the Chelly that are normally
down low are taking the melody
um oh it's so beautiful and then I just
build and build and it's just like
just jaw-droppingly beautiful yeah and
she's a sympathetic character in that in
that movie yes but this is where this is
where we can we can talk Trek I think
the movie itself is controversial some
people love it some people hate it I
love it as a historical Oddity that you
just have to remember that there was no
Wrath of Khan and TNG it was just the
show that had arguably failed a cartoon
that had failed and this weird movie
that kind of failed but they were all
spectacular in their own way and
Goldsmith this is where honestly I think
he saw Star Wars come out and was like
bro I can do that because it's like did
you're you're obviously looking at me
going this character must be one of the
most Immortal characters in film like in
Dr Zhivago no no she's like a weird
alien that turns into a robot and turns
into a robot that has vaginal
connotations like it's so weird it's so
weird sorry that's so weird there's
there's like alien anuses and all kinds
of weird [ __ ] in this one it's true
though no I feel like I'm gonna watch
this I mean Spock has to go through the
orifice that is like it's very sexual
and super weird but what I'm saying is
Goldsmith went uh-huh uh-huh Star Wars
had just come out and he was like I can
do that I'll do that exactly so he wrote
a soaring epic theme and then this Love
Theme that like man only he could have
written or is it a lovely I don't I
don't know it's just this thing that
floats above the Moon yeah yeah that's
why for me it is a piece of music
outside of the context of the film but
that's the absurdity of it right that
it's like Jerry Goldsmith wrote
something that the movie didn't need
You could argue like didn't even make
sense in the context of the movie like
it's so emotional but he was a
workaholic and I believe a genius and he
just he's the kind of guy that could he
didn't save it for something else he's
like I'm gonna put that Melody there
yeah and then the next thing that comes
along you know what the next movie he
did was like alien probably I'm gonna do
that I'll do it yeah I'll do another one
I'll do another one and Elmer Bernstein
was his generation he was like that too
he would sit at the piano and uh when I
was organizing scores in his studio and
he would just kind of sit down and like
mess around when he had five minutes and
then I'd look at him and go Elmer what
what score was that he's like I don't
know I'm just messing around it's not
it's nothing and you realize these guys
that condition themselves and train
themselves you know to just output what
we would say is genius work which goes
back to what I was saying earlier about
as a consumer you you worship it it
becomes a deity like oh my God that's so
genius is it genius or is it just at
that point in his life what Jerry
Goldsmith could do on Tuesday yeah
that's what it actually was even though
for me it's like that's genius if I
write a piece of music half as good as
elia's theme before I die I'll go man I
made it do you know what I mean yeah so
there you go that's funky we it is
definitely funky we like to rate these
funky Things based on Funk level don't
like a funk meat yeah
what would the meter well how would we
well the lower uh level of funk is
Brahms who is not generally seen as
being classically funky okay and what
would the top level all the way up to
the top which is uh princess most purple
yep okay so if you could think of an
artist that sits somewhere in that
category I'm gonna go first I'm gonna
say uh David Bowie is a lad insane well
that's that's sweet pretty funky yeah
it's pretty funky what if I said uh
Leonard Nimoy singing Bilbo's theme oh
that's fun kids
funky if you do you want a market in any
way yeah like in terms of funk level I
mean
I think it's somewhere uh sitting around
um boy the uh the Bilbo Baggins song is
good
no it's funny because I'm also thinking
like now my brain is going down that
path
um where there's a whip there's a way
what what was that which by the way
legit is funky um
where there's a whip there's a wave and
they had dinosaurs
yeah that's like I could have that that
could be a level of funky yeah you could
join me with that I think I'm happy you
have if I can get to the end of rings of
power and find a place to quote both the
Bilbo Baggins song and where there's a
whip and there's a way but in like a big
orchestral setting you know just just
gorgeous and French horns and strings
and just have people go that Melody yeah
I I want to do it I don't know if it'll
happen
well we'll watch this space Bear yeah
um yeah let's make it happen the music
you are doing in it is just beautiful
better and it's even better now that uh
I've met you and now you have as well
yeah it's always nice
yeah and the more I speak to you as well
and find out where you kind of came from
with your music and then you hear it in
the music it's just it's it makes it it
makes it even better I I appreciate you
saying that I feel like music is so
incredibly personal as much as one
thinks that you can write in somebody
else's style like you can't like I can
only write what I what I am and I am
what I am
today and if I wrote something today it
might be different than what I write
tomorrow well the the music you have
written and the world you've created and
go to war and bow star and Outlander and
and Rings a poem uh I would implore
everyone and go and listen to that stuff
I appreciate that Jensen thanks for
everything you guys have done to create
things that inspired me uh on as I was
on my path to uh to to do what I do I
mean I feel like that's the great thing
about art is that you get to everybody
gives to everybody else yeah and
everybody inspires everybody else well
it's been great having you on there um
yeah we'll run out of time so tell them
tell people where they can um send voice
message yeah if you'd like to get in
touch with us you could do that wherever
you subscribe and rate and review your
podcast and you can also get in touch
with us on our YouTube page which is the
Friendship onion friendship onions on
YouTube and then you can send messages
on speakpipe.com
friendship onion and uh oh you can get
merch at the friendshiponianpodcast.com
I mean that's it right and then go and
listen to Bear McCreery music why
wouldn't you watch the shows that he's
done watch the rings of power and we'll
see you guys next week on the Friendship
onion
[Music]
harmonize with me
[Music]